Das ist der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Heute mit unserer Nullnummer, dazu begrüße ich bei mir und ich freue mich sehr, Frank Helmstoth, den Ed Helmin. Es ist mal wieder soweit Nullnummernzeit.
Nullnummernzeit ist immer die schönste Zeit. Neue Nullnummer heißt neues Format.
Ja, es ist eine schöne, aber auch hektische Zeit. Mich freut es, dritte Nullnummer, die wir zusammen aufnehmen.
Ja, mich freut es auch, sehr sogar. Dritte Nullnummer, drittes Format. Spannend. Erzähl doch mal, was gibt es Neues?
Ja, es gibt jetzt den Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Und rate mal, was die Eigenschaft des Kurzpasses sein soll.
Ich komme nicht drauf.
Er wird steil gespielt. Nee, er soll tatsächlich kurz sein. Und jetzt lachen wahrscheinlich alle.
Ja, das bietet sich insofern an, da wir ja quasi in der Zeit, in der Rasenfunk-Geschichte bisher gelernt haben, wenn wir was nicht können, dann kurz.
Ja, was heißt nicht können? Wir wollten es ja auch nicht. Also beziehungsweise unterschiedlich. Also die Legende besagt, die wahr ist, weil es meine Erinnerung ist, wollte ich immer ein bisschen kürzer und du wolltest immer ein bisschen länger. Und inzwischen bin ich mehr in deine Richtung gegangen.
Was mich sehr freut, ja.
Ich kann inzwischen damit auch besser leben. Sonst würden wir es ja nicht machen. Ja, also das hier ist der Kurzpass und er soll kürzer sein. Wie kurz? Das sagen wir euch mal lieber nicht. In Rasenfunk-Zeiten kann kurz natürlich auch bedeuten, nur zwei Stunden, aber ein bisschen drunter soll es dann schon sein.
Ja, in der Regel werden wir wohl wahrscheinlich drunter kommen. Naja, Ziel ist natürlich halt wirklich, vielleicht mal spontan Ereignisse mitnehmen zu können und auch eine gute Sendung dazu zu machen, ohne sich für drei Stunden Inhalte vorzubereiten. Und natürlich einfach das Ganze auch ein bisschen kompakter zu vermitteln. Und das braucht mit Sicherheit manchmal etwas länger und manchmal geht es noch kürzer, aber wir werden uns bemühen.
Ich bin gespannt, wo allein diese Nullnummer landet. Ansonsten wird euch eigentlich alles so erwarten, wie ihr es von Schlusskonferenz und Tribünengespräche kennt. Ein bis mehrere Gäste. Es kann gut sein, dass da Frank mal drin vorkommt. Es kann gut sein, dass ich drin vorkomme. Ist sogar relativ wahrscheinlich, würde ich mal sagen. Das einzige, was fehlt, ist die charmante Julia, die wir aus dem Intro gekickt haben. Das soll ich jetzt sprechen. Mal gucken, ob ihr euch daran gewöhnen könnt, liebe Hörer. Wann geht es denn los, Frank?
Ja, zur Europameisterschaft. Da wird es die ersten Ausgaben fehlen. Fehlen natürlich nicht. Da wird es die ersten Ausgaben geben. Das ist insofern mega, weil es natürlich auch unser erstes Turnier ist für den Rasenfunk. Und die erste Erfahrung darum ist mit Sicherheit noch so ein bisschen, bisschen rantasten und ranfühlen, wie es genau aussehen wird, ist noch unklar, aber klingt sehr spannend, würde ich sagen.
Also ihr seht, liebe Hörer, es ist für euch genauso spannend wie für uns. Aber wir freuen uns, dass wir das neue Format haben, dass wir damit die Möglichkeit haben, auch mal kürzere Sendungen rauszuhauen, auch mal spontaner zu reagieren auf Dinge, die im Fußball passieren. Und wir finden, das ist eine ganz gute Ergänzung zu dem Tribütengespräch, in dem wir monothematisch lange Sendungen machen mit viel Tiefe, viel, viel, viel Tiefe, also Marianningraben mäßig. Und die Schlusskonferenz, wo wir auf dem Bundesligaspiertag zurückblicken wollen, das soll auch so bleiben. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, wie sich der Kurzpass in diesem Triumvirat so einfügt und ob das ein magisches Dreieck wird aus diesen drei Sendungen. Ich mich auch. Ich würde sagen, damit soll es das schon gewesen sein. Auch die Nullnummer des Kurzpasses soll kurz gewesen sein. Frank, wie machen wir das eigentlich mit dem Outro? Ja, glaube ich ehrlich gesagt. Wir werden aber halt auch besser beim Nullnummer aufnehmen, das muss man auch mal sagen. Wie viele Anläufe wir bei der ersten Nullnummer gebraucht haben, das war ja furchtbar.
Ja, das ist einfach deine Souveränität über gefühlt 380 Folgen Schlusskonferenz, die das Ganze jetzt deutlich entspannter gestaltet.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir echt aufhören, jetzt habe ich auch keinen Bock mehr. Wie machen wir das mit dem Intro? Mit dem Outro. Mit dem Outro, genau. Soll ich die Ramp wieder drunterlegen, so wie immer?
Schmeiß halt mal irgendwas rein und start mal irgendwas und wir verabschieden uns dann. Wir machen das einfach mal ganz spontan.
Ja, dann habt ihr hiermit etwas Historisches gehört, liebe Hörer, und zwar die erste Ausgabe des Kurzpasses. Abonniert ihn, sagt es weiter euren Freunden, dass es ihn gibt. Und auch hier freuen wir uns natürlich wieder wahnsinnig über iTunes-Rezensionen, oder, Frank?
Ja, mindestens. Übrigens das Tribünengespräch braucht auch noch ein paar. Und geben wir jetzt den Kurzpass unter rasenfunk.de slash kurzpass.
Und deswegen sagen wir vielen Dank fürs Hören bis hierhin. Bis bald mal.
Danke, bis bald. Ciao.